what's going on everybody welcome to
part 10 of the web development in Python
with Django tutorials where we left off
we were creating the models which point
to each other by way of foreign key and
in this tutorial we want to actually
interact with those models using those
foreign keys if you are starting here
it's assumed you have tutorials and if I
click on these tutorials I see that they
have series if I edit this series I can
see hey this series is part of a
specific category and so on make sure
you have that if you don't have that go
to the text-based version in this
tutorial and write it hopefully at the
top somewhere I'll put a download at the
end of each tutorial I've been saving
the you know the version up to that
point so we should have tutorial you
know downloads at the end of every
tutorial just in case you get lost for
whatever reason you can download my
version so let's get started so the main
issue we're having here is like with
full-length tutorials you can see this
is absurd right so instead on the home
page we want to have categories like I
do with Python programming dotnet now
when I click on one of these categories
you can see here there's just like one
slug and then if I click again I'm I'm
no I'm using the wrong terminology there
I actually don't know what you would
call that we'll talk about that in a
second but if I also click on the data
analysis with pandas series it's also
all contained within like one set of
slashes I guess whereas a lot of times
like a lot of websites would do
something maybe like this like data
analysis and then maybe pandas intro or
something like that I just never did
that and also it would be much longer
than that because you'd have think it
would just be longer than that and
that's my main constraint with that is I
I just don't really like having really
really long URLs so I just kind of threw
everything under one set of slashes but
this can be pretty hard when you start
to try to make dynamic URLs and use like
logic within your your URLs so I'll show
you guys what I mean when we get into it
but just know if like if I was starting
with like Python programming and that
from scratch I probably wouldn't do this
again but this is the way it is and I
don't want to change those URLs
I don't want to serve like a hard
redirect or something so this is the way
it is because those URLs are like ranked
in Google
I just don't mess with that so anyways
that's what we're gonna be doing so
let's get started we got a lot of stuff
to do so the first thing we're gonna do
is pop into let's close these and yeah
go into views and what I want to do is
basically add a new function in here for
what I'm gonna refer to as single slug
III don't know what you would call that
like when you only have like one slash
of stuff or what happens when you have
like two slashes of stuff like what what
would the naming be or is there no name
I don't even know but I'm gonna call it
like if it only like this would be a you
know double slug or something like that
whereas this there's only one set in
there so I'm gonna call that a single
slug I know this can't be the word but
that's what I'm going with
so now what we want to do is from our
models we want to make sure we import
everything so that would be tutorial
category as well as tutorial series then
what we're gonna do is begin define
single slug and this will take requests
as always but also single slug because
we can accept a variable through the URL
path and I'll show you guys how to do
that but just know that that we're going
to be passing that through the URL path
and our URLs dot pi so then we're gonna
say so basically our issue here at this
point is when we click on something or
we have a slug right we need to
determine is this a category or is it a
tutorial all right because it could be
either one of those things we don't know
also you might be wondering well what
about like a contact page or
registration that's a single slug as
well well the URL path the pattern is
gonna match that that first so we're
gonna put the single slug thing at like
the bit bottom of our URL spy paths this
way if it does match something else
that'll match something else first
before we match
no just randomly single slug why did it
go down okay
anyway so at this point we need to
determine is this a category or a
specific tutorial we don't need to worry
about tutorials series because every
tutorial will have a sidebar for
navigating throughout that entire series
so when you go to the category and you
want to click on it like the category
will display all the series when you
click on a series it's going to start
you at part 1 of that tutorial you don't
really need to know much more than that
so in any given URL you only need to
know is this a category URL or a
tutorial URL so first we need to know
okay what are all the categories and
this is a perfect example of one reason
why you would want to use foreign keys
because we can just iterate over the
category table rather than iterating
over every single tutorial compiling a
list of all the categories that they say
they're a part of and then creating like
a set or something like that that would
be messy we don't really want to do that
and this is already messy so we don't
want that so categories we're gonna say
C dot category flips actually see that
category slug for C in tutorial category
dot objects dot all so that gives us a
list of possible categories if single
slug is in that cat there's in
categories then we know this is a
category so we're gonna were just return
for now an HTTP response we'll make it a
little more fancy and a little bit HTTP
response and we'll just say single slug
is a category okay great then we want to
do the same thing for tutorials so I'm
just gonna copy that paste I'm gonna
just change this now to tutorials we'll
say T and then we'll do tutorial slug
for T in tutorial the objects dot all
then if there is no match what do we do
well we'll just return another HTTP
response and we'll just say in theory
this is going to handle our 404 so keep
in mind if we've gotten all the way to
this point and then we return this this
has now handled for our 404 for
everything under single slashes so you
would actually probably want to return
some sort of 404 Django actually has a
special 404 response so I'm just letting
you know that exists but for now I'm
just gonna say this single slug does not
correspond to anything good enough okay
great
so now what we want to do is set up our
home page to display categories so what
we're gonna say now is under here
home page should you show all of our
categories rather than tutorials so
we're gonna say tutorial category not
objects dot all and then we're gonna say
[Music]
categories dot HTML we're gonna call
this category cat categories and for
these HTML pages since I've already sent
you once probably to the text base right
up anyways I think I'm gonna copy and
paste these there's nothing new here I
just don't want to waste any time on the
HTML side of things I'll still explain
everything but there there's nothing new
here so but it so I don't really see
much point in wasting time there because
we got we have so much stuff to cover
here so we're gonna go into my site main
templates main and then I'm just gonna I
think is it home
I think it's home that that's pretty
similar but anyway it doesn't really
matter I'm going to copy and paste
effort I already forgot that was my plan
categories dot H
actually starting HTML document so
categories come into here
yeah it's gonna be very very similar to
this it's gonna be just we're going to
iterate over the categories rather than
tutorials but like I said I'm just gonna
copy and paste just in case we mess up
somewhere okay so all this does is
iterate over the categories it links to
the category slug and then it is the
title is the category title and then it
gives the category summary okay so I'm
actually gonna delete this we don't need
published there okay so very similar to
what was there before we haven't really
changed much so yeah so we'll save that
and come back to our main page let's
refresh oops we don't want to be oh
that's okay we weren't on first art I
guess we haven't loaded admin yeah
anyway here we are so we got
fundamentals data analysis and if we
click on either one of these the hope oh
we didn't add our URLs DUP hi of course
of course
okay let's do that noob come on guys I
was just his test I wanted to see if
anybody in in the class was gonna say
hey you didn't add the URLs okay and you
guys failed so anyway okay so single
slug that's our path and we use these
like you know greater than less than
signs to denote a this is a variable now
and we want to be able to pass this
variable to the function that we're
going to pass which is views dot C
single slug and the name we're gonna
call this just single slug and then I
might add a comma here so I don't forget
next time okay I think we're actually
ready so let's try that again
cool so we see here when we click on
fundamentals it says hey this is a
category so we knew it's a category and
now we need to display that category in
some way same thing with data analysis
data analysis is a category okay so it
knows the logic works great
so let's say we know fundamentals is a
category now what well now what we need
to be able to do is find all of the
tutorials that are in the category where
that categories slug is Python
fundamentals so that's a little
challenging because our categories do
have the foreign key that is the series
but the series then has a foreign key
that is the category and then the
category has an attribute that's the
slug so we have to make a couple of
jumps here which would be easier if the
category was possibly in the same table
as the tutorial but like I said before
you wouldn't really want that because
your database lookups would be these
huge queries and you don't wouldn't want
to make that happen
so instead what we'll do now is go back
to views and and what we want to do yeah
[Music]
let's say we make a match here so just
for the category we want to find the
matching tutorial series who's who's
category has a category slug that is
what we passed so before I said I think
I said tutorial and I was mistaken
so really what we're trying to do is
we're just trying to find the tutorial
series because we want to link to the
entire series let's say so in this case
the way we're gonna do that is matching
series equals tutorial series because
that's what we're looking for at the end
of the day is tutorial series objects
dot filter and what we want to fill
where we how we want to filter is first
like let's open up that models because
this is this is where you're gonna have
to probably the hardest time yeah so
tutorial series how do we go from
tutorial series to category slug well
first we have to make the hop with this
foreign key right
we need to find the tutorial category so
tutorial series we're gonna filter by
category okay which points to tutorial
category but we and we want category
slug from there so the real question is
how do we make that hop and attributes
because both are not intuitive so let's
see let's see so matching series
tutorial series objects dot filter the
first thing is we need to go to a
tutorial in this case we want to say
tutorial category because that's your
foreign key and then you need to point
to the slug so we're gonna say filter
and we want to filter by tutorial
tutorial category and then it points to
that tutorial categories attribute so in
this case you use a double underscore
like that and then we will say category
slug so if we go back to our models
tutorial category and then now to
reference this attribute you use a
double underscore then the actual thing
that you're trying to go for so in this
case category slug okay so coming back
over here so we want to filter whether
the tutorial categories category slug is
what and actually nope nope quotes there
single slug so that gives us the
matching tutorial series now from there
we want to be able to like display them
similarly to how we display our
categories so if I go back here you see
it's like a little card it has a name
maybe a description if we click on it
sends us to a URL well what URL do we
use for a tutorial series well you could
if you get fancy and send them to like
the last tutorial that the user
specifically left off on or you could
just send them to part one I'm for now
gonna make it simple and we're gonna
send them to just part one
okay so we need to get the URL for part
one tutorial of the tutorial series that
matches that category slug okay okay
so luckily we've already got the
matching mm matching series so then we
just need to find the tutorials that are
part ones from those matching series and
then we just kind of cascade them so
okay whoa to do that for EM in matching
series dot all so we're gonna iterate
over all of those what do we want to do
first we need to get the part one URLs
so we're gonna say part one and this
will be another giant filter operation
that will be a tutorial dot objects stop
filter and we want to filter and again
we're gonna make these hops right so
we're gonna filter first by tutorial so
tutorial find the foreign key so we're
gonna filter we're tutorials series
which then points to this series and
then here tutorial series so we want to
make sure that that tutorial series
equals that same series like so we want
to find the tutorials that match the
tutorial series that were matching
series two that slug okay so first we
want to make that operation so let me
write that first and then we'll add the
rest that we want so tutorial underscore
series underscore underscore tutorial
series and again this might be like way
overkill for some people I apologize but
I feel like this is like the most
confusing bit of all this because like
the double underscores is annoying but
let's talk about how that worked
so too we started at this tutorial
object which is here then we say
tutorial series that's that one this one
and then double underscore because this
is a foreign key we're pointing up to
here pointing to this tutorial series
which actually is that care car filled
okay which will match M
because em recall that's the object
itself and it'll be the same car field
so all we would say would be M which is
that now this is a tutorial object I'm
sorry a tutorial series object would be
M in this case and then we just want to
get m dot tutorial tutorial series okay
so this returns us all of the tutorial
objects that are a part of that tutorial
series so it's not part one yet all this
does is gives us all of the tutorials
that are a part of that series now if we
want part one we can use an attribute
dot earliest and to know about that you
would just need to like I would visit
the Django docs and learn about all the
attributes that you can make but we can
use fancy magical things like this
because one of our attributes is a
date/time type so as we come over here
published
is this like date/time field so Django
will just know that we can use like it
just supplies us basically with the
ability to use this little method here
so we're gonna say dot earliest by
tutorial published so we'll just go by
the publish date we'll just assume for
now the publish date the one that got
published first that would be part one
okay so that is our part one whew okay
so then what I'm gonna have us do is I
think for matching series we'll just
pass this this dictionary basically so
we're gonna say series and URLs is equal
to a dict and then we'll come down here
and then we'll just say series URLs M
equals part one so M is the tutorial
object so we could get the title of
publish all that kind of stuff or
actually I'm sorry this will be the
tutorial series object so we can get the
name the description and so
and then part one will be the link so
the key is the object the value is the
URL so that's everything we should need
up to this point so rather than
returning this silly HTTP response
let's return a render request hold on I
gotta fix this mess I created okay cool
and then the template will be main dot
category cuz it's a specific category
HTML and then our context we'll just say
part ones and that is series URLs that
should be good enough okay
now what we need to do is create
category HTML and again I'm just gonna
copy and paste this there's nothing new
here it's just I don't want to spend a
bunch of time on this one especially
because this will be probably bug-ridden
if I if I try to write it all alive but
it's very it's gonna be very very
similar we just need to iterate over
these new objects and there will be some
new code not will explain it so anyway
i'm gonna copy and paste that from the
text base tutorial and so here this was
probably the only new code that you
haven't seen i'm gonna get rich together
in this case this is like this is key in
value okay so this is our way to grab
out key and value because tutorial here
is the specific tutorial series object
so this will be a tutorial tutorial
series at your object and then this is
the series summary but yeah the only
really new looking thing here is this
right here and that's just how we how we
can split apart key and value and it's
super simple okay so at this point let's
go to our website I don't think we need
to refresh but we'll do it click on
fundamentals drink it what do we do
wrong views
why didn't that serious category wait
did I not I'm pretty sure I saved that
but hold on let me just do this again I
swear I saved it like I I see that I had
a little dot there but I swear I looked
at that anyway I guess I didn't save it
refresh that so we click on fundamentals
and now we see there's the Python basics
and we have intermediate Python so let's
click on one of them
Python basics boom and it says uh it
says this one doesn't correspond to
anything I wonder if it's because of our
ooh
that's probably because of our space is
probably well let me go back let's go to
this one real quick what did I do wrong
there we definitely have an error here
oh oh I know what I did I already know
it yeah part one yeah okay
part one is the tutorial which if we
just referenced the tutorial it's gonna
be the title of that tutorial which is
why I'm seeing all these like percent
20s that spaces so what we need to say
is part one da tutorial slug not a
capital s like that save okay come back
to home page do it still doesn't
correspond to anything oh man I don't
mean okay we gotta figure out what we've
done wrong there so introduction to
Python program
tutorials TDOT tutorial slug Oh we've
still got Wow
too many typos man okay so we need to
check if single slug is in tutorials
it's too early in the morning guys I
there we go finally no does this a suit
it's a cat oh wait that's another yeah
more espresso ah
okay I'm ready to go all right to torrid
so in this case single slug is a to Tori
all start those motors there we go okay
finally how come nobody brought that up
when I wrote that okay so from the home
page we can click on fundamentals we see
Python basics intermediate Python let's
say we want to intermediate Python boom
okay it knows it's a tutorial
congratulations everybody we did it yeah
or we could click on data analysis data
vis let's say okay knows it's a tutorial
knows is it okay whew alright I think
that's a good stopping point you know
deal quick shout out to my most recent
channel members I'm Marco Joey Santana
and Fredrik thank you guys very very
much send me more coffee please
okay I think we'll stop here and in in
the next one what we'll focus on is
actually doing this bit I don't want to
do this bit right now
I need to let this coffee simmer and
maybe later I will film again hopefully
a little more awake anyway what we want
to do here is display the tutorial and
then maybe we'll do like the navbar like
I have a nav bar on Python programming
done yet so we go here then let's just
go to any one of these there's like this
little side nav bar like wherever you
are you can click go you know and it
knows that you're on that one and stuff
like that so we do something similar
fairly easily and it'll give me an
opportunity to show you a couple more
little helper functions but at the end
of the day a lot of this stuff is
like with earliest for example that's a
Google search or you could just quickly
scroll through the docs just to see like
what's available to you but in general
you're not gonna memorize all of the
possibilities you shouldn't actually be
able to sit down like totally write out
a django website without ever having to
look anything up that's just impractical
nobody codes like that despite what they
want you to think so so anyway keep that
in mind the one thing I will say is kind
of like with part one that I told you
about I would strongly advise that you
try to write these queries all on your
own this is something you should be able
to do you know not withstanding the
earliest bit right you don't have to
remember all of those although in this
case you should you just went over it so
you should remember that but try to
write these because the double
underscores and the linking can be kind
of confusing I'm sure for some of you
guys you guys were like on my internet
Sampo but at least for me the first
couple of times I needed to write one of
these queries I was like wait what try
to figure out how to do it yeah okay
that can get kind of kind of a pain so
try to write both of those on your own
because I think that's probably gonna be
the weakest point for some people but
maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm just stupid
anyways I will see you guys in the next
video